just a couple of moments ago Jim
Reynolds chairman and CEO Luke capital
markets he was speaking to our Betty Lou
at the Aspen ideas festival he said whoa
Rico has significant structural problems
the populations aging that debt load is
Stephanie mentioned 72 billion dollars
Puerto Rico can't pay and he said they
can't tax their way out they can't grow
their way out how did we get to this
point I mean it's just a massive amount
of debt right i mean they over borrowed
and it's about it's a lot about in
efficiencies as well and we know we
didn't have a great efficiency in the
government and you had a lot of people
then leaving going to the mainland so
all of those problems have compounded
and it's just a big debt problem at this
point so if you are one of the
distressed investors was this a positive
or was this a negative I mean don't you
want to keep pushing them so they're so
desperate they have to take whatever
terms you offer yes but if you push them
too far and they can't actually pay back
anything even a court you know can't
necessarily help you get money if
there's actually nothing to get paid
back okay the Puerto Rico is not gonna
end up in that situation I'm hopefully
not right i mean if we can fix things
get the economy going again then people
can get their money back if Puerto Rico
does start defaulting on these bonds
what about the muni market if that
starts to happen you know some people
have side of Puerto Rico's quite
isolated you know we've known that this
is a problem for a while but I think
you'll start to see other municipalities
like Chicago start to have some of these
issues where people say we'll look we're
gonna we're gonna try to do this
differently here Laura there's been a
lot of talk why not just declare
bankruptcy why is that not an option
structurally they can't Kenny no legally
they're not allowed Porto Rico is not
allowed to actually access chapter 9 now
there have been a lot of things going on
in Congress on Chuck Schumer you know
put support behind a new bill yesterday
um Nancy Pelosi has mentioned it the
White House's mentioned it so we might
get to see here where some people on
Capitol Hill are gonna start talking
about this bill and actually allow
Porter equal public corporations to file
for bankruptcy but that wouldn't include
the actual state of Puerto Rico and some
the agency's there and you are seeing
the politicians of Puerto Rico push for
that